みなさん、こんにちは。これは
アクティブな推論ゲスト ストリーム 28.1 です
。2022 年 10 月 14 日です。
今日は
、Giovanni Rolla による合理性の再考について聞き、議論する予定です。Giovanni は
、このプレゼンテーションと議論を非常に楽しみにして参加していただきありがとうございます。
ありがとうございます。
数か月前に招待状を受け取って光栄でした。
ここ
に来て、私の仕事について話し合う機会を持てたことを
うれしく思います。あなたのリクエストは
割愛します。私たちの提案です。
これを提示します。 私が数年前に書いた論文で
、舞台裏で話していたとき、
私は何
度か考えを変えました。その論文
を発表して以来、プレゼンテーション中にこれを明確にするつもりです
が、それは
喜びです それにもかかわらず、
このビデオをここ
で発表し、世界と共有する機会を得て、非常に
満足しています。
合理性を再考することについて話し合う予定です。これが
旅程です。 私は
あなたに提示することを考えていたので、最初に
合理性と
コンテンツのない認知について話し、次に
根本的に
不活発な合理性と安全な言葉
と呼んだ私の見解を提示します。 異議の
最初のものは、
私がここにいるものは何でも
、過度にリベラルな意味で真のリベラルで
あり、あまりにも
多くを包含しているという
ことです. もちろん
、私たちの予測コーディングの予測プロセスは
、中央の2台の車の近くにあり、
積極的な影響を与える
ためのもの
です。
申し訳ありません
が、この問題に関する私の最初の考えは
、伝統的に非常に
正統派であるということです。 合理性についての見解を持っている
ええと、私の知る
限りでは、合理性が彼らの推論において必要であるというのは実際には仮定であると想定しています。
ブレを引き受ける理由が存在する
場合に限り、行動においてBが合理的で
あると私は信じています。もちろん
、理由の質問は、
古典的な論理や確率の推論などの特定の形式的なベンチマークで取得する必要があります。
この伝統的な映画に従って合理的に信じて行動するヒューリスティックスは、
特定の正式な基準を満たす
必要が
あります. 推論が
特定の正式なベンチマークに対する信念の評価を伴う
場合、合理性
は認識のための
コンテンツを意味します。コンテンツ
は、
正しいか間違っているか、またはより
重要な概念が真か偽である可能性がある正確さの条件を最小限に持っていると私は考えます。
ここでの考え方は、合理性には
必然的に内容が含まれ、
信念が含まれるということです。 推論と比較、または
今すぐ
更新して申し訳ありませんが、ソフトウェアの更新が1つあります。申し訳ありませんが
、ここのウィンドウにポップアップが表示されていたので
、合理性に関する標準的な見方だと思います。
合理性が必然的に
関与する場合 内容それは、
古典的な認知主義または一般的な認知主義とうまく適合し
ます。これは、組み合わせが
必然的
に少なくとも一部の
認知主義者にとっては、もちろんそれは概念的な内容も含むかもしれませんが、
少なくとも表象的な内容を含む可能性があるという見解です。
正確な条件です
が、この古典的な見方はあまり良くないので
、
私がここで最近の本でグッドウィン・メインによる急進的で行動主義について特に考えているわけではありません
が、
他の問題にも挑戦していると思います。
急進的で積極的であるとして提示されていないビューです
が、もちろん、急進的で活動的ないくつかのコアテナントを共有しています
私たちはそれらを、ええと、エゼキエル・パウエルまたはバーマンの感覚モデルの人生によって提示された見解など、認識の根本的に具現化された見解と呼ぶことができ
ます。また、
ギャラガーの2017年の本にはさまざまな非活動
主義
があり、トニー・キメロによる彼の見解も意味します 2009 年の
生態学的心理学と動的
システムに関する本 それらはすべて共通のテナントを共有して
おり、ここで私はこれが非常に
物議をかもしていることを知っていますが、私はそれらの
見解を根本的に具現化された
認識の
見解として
扱っています。
彼らは皆、認識は
表象的で満足のいくもので
はないと言っています。つまり、基本的な
内容のない認識の形態、
または自分の環境の積極的な探索を通じて出現する内容のないレベルの基本的なレベルの
認識
を考えることができ、
ラディカルとアクティビズムを超えて 私たちが
意味
することは、このアイデアは、
感覚運動の関与を習得するという点でキャッシュアウトされる可能性が
あるということです。  -自分の周りに物事があれこれ
あることを知るのではなく、自分の周囲とどのように関わるかを
知ること
は、パウロと
同僚、そして例えば
キメロが彼らの本の中で行っていることであることが非常に明確です。
感覚
モデルの取り組み 感覚モデルの
スキーム など、
しかし最近の開発では
、これが組み込まれていると思います。つまり、これは
このアイデアの要点の使用です。
したがって
、反芻または過激派と活動主義
と古典的な燃料の過激な具体化されたビューを組み合わせると、
私たちが持っている合理性は、アングルが
次のように説明したものです
.アクティビズムとは、認識が祈りに基づいているという見解で
あり、現実の状況の感覚運動の獲得に基づいた世界の
合理的な理解であり、彼はこれらを説明しています。
メロペンチン・ハイデガーの考えによる合理的理解
、世界との関係はpに根ざした唯一のものであり得る
演技や
インターンの実践における実践の非活動は身体を介して媒介される
ため、ここで暗黙的に思われること
は、演技や実践とは異なり、
合理性は実際
には組み合わせの非常に基本的なレベルではないものではないということです。
能動的かつ実際に
根ざした基本レベルの認識のための余地を作り、上位レベルの組み合わせから切り離す.
それらは通常、
合理性の幸運な古典的な場所である.
運動の
関与は合理的ではない
ので、感覚的な現代の関与ですが
、多産の美徳は合理性の観点から評価することはできません。
認知の
高レベルの組み合わせの内容のみが合理
的な定義になり得
ます。
紙の上では触れていませんが、それ
は私の暗黙の動機でした 精神の
哲学から来た誰か
が、与えられた神話の考えであるとして、この主題を扱い
ます。当時の私には少なくともそれのバージョンのように見えました。
私の最初のプレゼンテーションでは非常に複雑でしたが、
基本的な認識を合理的な思考
と行動から分離し
、
井戸を指さしなければ
、これら2つのレベルの交差はありません。つまり、
急進主義と活動主義と ええと、同様の
見解は、私の心の
横柄な分野の問題として、セラーズによって不人気になった所与の神話と
マクダウェルによるモデレーションにコミットされ
ているので、これは
[音楽]
は哲学的に興味深い問題
だと思いますが、 ええと
、論文の最前線で、ここでの私の
暗黙の動機は、感覚的な現代的な取り組みを通じて
、内容のないまたは基本的なレベルの認知を比率とどのように組み合わせることができるかを説明すること
でした。
もし
あなたがそれができないなら、
ある種の与えられたものがあり
、私たちの心の絵では完全には説明されていない
ようです。だからこれは
私が望んでいたことです。
これには触れ
ませんでしたが、
今日私が示すのはなぜなのかという方向に何か
があると思います。これ
は、与えられたという神話にコミットしているというこの告発
をピンセットする方法だと思います。
その
問題を回避し、互いに
完全に分離された 2 つのレベルがあるという考えを回避するために、より高いレベルが
古典的な合理性の軌跡であり、
その下にあるものは合理的では
ないと思います。
定義しなければならないか、
必然的に推論を伴う必要
がありますが、推論を考える必要はありませんが、推論ではない場合の合理性とは何かについて積極的な提案
を提供することが課題になります。
アーリーは
論文で、私の知識はこの主題に関する唯一のものであり、
彼女は当時のところ
で与えられた神話についても心配していた
と思います。彼は
ここからの長い引用です。
集中型階層関係の複雑なシステムから出現するかもしれません
抑制の促進と
異なる水平層の間の調整
それぞれが動的で環境
に基づいた合理性であり、
水平またはモジュールの用語で再考されます ええと
、彼女がこの用語を使用しなければならないかどうかはわかりません
が、 いずれにせよ、
それは彼女が表現するために選んだ方法であり
、環境と持続的に関連して
いる 生物
全体または垂直に境界付けられた
中央認知モジュールのコンテンツなど、入力と出力の間を仲介する内部手順だけに
依存するのではなく、依存している n の
特定の側面を監視して応答するレイヤーを含む、専用の World 間の複雑な関係
自然環境と社会環境
、そしてニューラルネットワークのフィードバックを減らし
、彼らの反応から彼らのフィードバックを減らします.これ
は、私の知る限り、ある方法で
非アクティブなアプローチに取り組んで
いる誰かの最も初期のケースです。
過激派やアクティビズムとは異なるアプローチ
であり、
私がその論文を書く前の私の知る限り
、これが最も
古いもの
であり、ネイティブの用語で再考された合理性の最も明確な提案ですが、それは彼女の出版後に
牽引力を得たものではありません
私の知識では、
実際にはそれ以来あまり見ていません。
アイデアを要約すると
、説明を変更する必要があるということ
です。合理性であるフォーカスは
、この提案の容量を含むコンテンツとしてのみ考えられるわけではあり
ません。
それ
は身体の形態と行動
、そして生物がどのように位置付けられて
行動するかに依存します その環境では、アイデア
は最小限に死んでいるので、これを
根本的に非アクティブな合理性
と呼んでいます。非常に
大まかな定義では、アジア
人
は、人間が自分の環境との熟練した相互作用を維持し、
認知能力を調整している限り、合理的に行動するということです。
制約
と堅実なステーションの環境条件に応じて、そしてもちろん、これ
は予期せぬ状況に適応することを必要とする場合もあります.
核となる直感はこれ
であり、2003年のテキストでスーザン・ハーレーの別の
アイデアと急進的で積極的な合理性のこのアイデアを比較することは興味深い.
彼女は行動
する理由を言う 行動する理由は、ガレス・エヴァンスの一般性制約に反論している文脈に縛られている可能性がある
と主張し
ている.
ここで推論しますが、この種の
推論は限界があります 実践的な
文脈から見れば、これは私が最初に話し
た伝統的な見方と比較すると非常に進歩的な
見方です
が、私
がここで開発しようとしているものよりもさらに保守的です。
提案
は、合理性は代理店と自律性を意味する
ということです。なぜなら
、有機体が行う何かまたは何かだけ
が合理的権利であると言えるからです。
これらを使用するには、
自律的で活動家の陣営からのアイデアと、
プレイヤーが次のような自律システムである方法の理論からのアイデアを使用します。
ルンバ
はエージェントではないため、合理的ではありません。ルンバ
自体の動作の作成者ではありません。
外部
エージェントによって特定の方法で機能するように設計されているため、
厳密に言えば国家ではありません。
たとえば、合理性をルンバに帰することは意味がありません。
このために、
私は自律性と適応性の概念を使用し
ます。
また、最近の本は
四感覚モデルの生活をイメージしており
、2005 年のボウルの有名な論文では、
ロシア人であることの意味に非常に一般的な制約
を設定するための適応性について語っているため、自律システムは
不安定なネットワークとして考えられています。
組織と物理的な境界が
システム自体によって生成されるため、プロセスの不安定なネットワーク システム
は継続的に独自の生存条件を維持してい
ます。これは
、システムが自己維持に有利な環境環境条件を調査した場合、意味形成として知られてい
ます。
これは、自律システムでなければならない
合理的な存在に対する感情的な制約であると私が理解している方法
です。ここで興味深いのは
、パウロが適応性の概念
4つ目は、
生物が自己生産の状態を改善する能力
です。 内部
構造の変化を
監視し、
調整する
ことで、利用可能な最善の行動方針を選択する必要があります。
根本的に
非アクティブな合理性の概念というこの考えを含めることは、別の興味深い概念だと思います。
必ずしも推論や内容に専念しているわけではない
ので、エージェンシーは、環境の制約とサブステーションに従って生物内の変化を促進する状況能力の行使を通じて実現され
ます。
これは、生物がその環境に上手に対処するためにどれだけうまく適応するかが尺度であることを意味します
生物がより合理的である
ほど
、その環境に対処するのに適し
ています。私たちは
状況
を予測しており、そうすることで、生物は
それ自体とその生存に不可欠な環境との間の継続的な交換を強化
します
。 それ
は合理性の非常に
自然な考え方です
主
に生存のための変化を強化する能力です
これが
ここでの全体的な考え方です
前に言ったように 推論についてはどうし
たいですか
合理性を必ずしも推論でコミットしたくはありません
以前の合理的な組み合わせとして推論を除外したくない
ので、私が言いたいのは、
それは推論によって定義され
ていないということですが、そうではありません.推論を除外するわけではありません。
これは私たち
人間の知識に限ったものです
が、それは合理性の決定的な特徴ではない
ので、この考えを説明するために、ウタニの
最新の本の論文の間にあるフツと土星がどのよう
に説明しているかを思い出します。
高い認知度の出現 認知の
ためのコンテンツに従事できることは、コンテンツの完全な
認知が社会から出現した場合、最終的には
社会的文化的に組み込まれることに依存するという考えです。
個人が社会
的文化的慣行
に参加するにつれて、彼ら
はシンボルを扱うより古い認知能力を受け入れ、
そうすることによって
、文化化の長いプロセスの中でもちろん
、彼らは内部的ではない象徴的な調整に従事することができるようになります。
それは公的に利用可能であるため
、伝統的な意味での心的表象ではありません
が、それは内部的表象または心的表象へのコミットメントのない象徴的認知の特徴を持っている
ため、最も一般
的な意味で合理的に
行動することは、 有機体はその環境における
有機体の熟達した行動であり
、体現された能力の調整に依存し
ますが、すべてがうまくいく場合の推論
はもちろん
、私の特定の合理性モードの
合理性の内容として理解されます。
社会的文化的環境における有機
体 もちろん、
環境は私たちの環境のより具体的な側面で
あり、それ
はそのような文化に
基づいた、または
人間の系統発生スケールでより最近の能力を含むコンテンツの調整に依存している
ため、これはアイデアの最大の
ものです。
ええと、プロポジティブな部分だと思います。最初
に話したかった異論は次のとおり
です。それは非常にリベラルな
見解であり、
非常にええと
です。合理的な行動
が調整に帰着する場合
認識能力の場合、合理性は
生物にとって緩やかなもの
であり、環境相互作用に多かれ少なかれ熟練している
可能性が
あり、拒絶は
根本的に非アクティブな合理性に従って行われ、多くの
生物
はニッチでの適応行動
を達成および維持します。
ええと、誰かが合理的
で積極的な急進的で積極
的な合理性をリベラルに歌うことができます。これは
私が個人的に聞いた異論の1つは、それを非常に良い方法
だと思うので、私はそれを一生懸命に保ちました。
財布
そうですね、
伝統的な見方よりもリベラルです もちろんそう
なるように意図されていますが、
これ自体の問題で
はないと思います ここでの肯定的な部分は、
人間の程度の違いを維持することです 他の動物よりもはるかに合理的である
理由は、私たちが認識している他の動物をはるかに超え
た、
さまざまな動的な状況でさまざまな行動を実行できるため
です。この爪の例に戻ると、
この爪はできます いくつかの複雑な
アクションを実行する ある地点から別の地点に移動する
ことができます 食べ物
や避難所などを探すことができますが
、
この釘を南で囲むと、
たとえば死ぬ運命にあるなど、限られた重要な能力があります
一方、反論と人間
ははるかに適応性が高く
、多くの予期せぬ状況に動的に対処することができます。
そのため
、その反対意見に対する私の回答は、
はい、
非常にリベラルですが、それ
は問題ではありません。
動物が環境に対処する方法の間に程度の違いの余地があった場合
、これは他のオブジェクトの
異議であり
、あなたが最も興味を持っ
ているのは12の予測処理です.
ずっと
推論と内容を暗示しているように見えますが、最初にあなたと視聴者に警告しなければなりません。
私がこれを書いた時点では、この論文
は
、アクティビズムと
予測コーディングまたは予測
処理を組み合わせる可能性についてはるかに楽観的でした。 ここには
重要なポイントがあると思いますが
、Olu と Evan Thompson と Randy ビールによるこの最近の論文
では、彼ら
は uh th の重要な評価を提供しています。
主
に自由エネルギー原理と
非活動
的で自伝的な理論を組み合わせようとする試みなので、私は現在、
ほとんどの議論に納得していますが、ここ
には興味深い比較ポイントがいくつかあると思いますが
、予測コードには予測プロセスが
あり、ええと 私が書いていた時
、そして今でも
認知科学の中で大流行しています.
お菓子が
主要なパラダイムの1つになったと言える
と思います.
これらのビューアでは、
競合が双方向の狭い階層
で発生するエラー最小化のプロセスとして理解されて
いる
ことを知って
いるため、下層の活動の内部モデルが生成され、
悪意のある刺激の遠位の原因が予測されます。 トップダウン
プロセスと、
予測と
現在の刺激信号との間の
不一致の最小化。
はプロセスの底部である
ため、ここではもちろんアクティブな推論
があります。たとえば、クラークの
正式な用語を知っている非公式に理解されます
彼らの
脳は、
これが非常に正式な用語に影響を与える能動的な言葉を理解する1つの方法であると期待して
いますが、
私はそれが仕事を
成し遂げ
ていると思います. そう話すと
、
製品バイアスと推論権を使用する予測処理の彼の投票の読み物は
、たとえば、
知覚
主義者のプロセスは、
増殖とコンテキストのトップダウン
効果の合理的なより広範なバイアスプロセスから分離可能であると述べてい
ます。 これを処理することは
、クラークが合理性についてずっと話しているように私の注意を引きました
が、それは n 推論的な
合理性
と普及したインフルエンサーの推論は、非浸透的な
コンテンツを暗示しているようで
あり、予測処理は
根本的に非アクティブ
な合理
性と相容れないように思われますが、当時は存在していまし
た。
-hemorrhoids と
、たとえば 1 つの最初のステップを使用する予測処理の読み取りは
、2013 年からの短い論文でカメオを理解するという予測のデフレ感覚を使用することですが、4 つ目で
、2 つ以上の変数の
値が共変または値の信頼性が高いため、
値が 1 の場合、オブザーバーは別の値を推測することができます。
ここで、
推測は
観察のレベルで起こっています。ある
変数ではなく、別の変数の値を推測している
ので、内容は次のようになります。
見る人
私たちが入れた検閲の選択が
ここで内部予測にどの
ように近似するかを解釈する人 彼のインフレの感覚
はそれを推論的で偏見のある言葉で説明できる
ので、
例えばブルーノの論文による 4000 についての考えをこの
ように見ることができます。タイトルが間違っていなければ、脳は
科学者ではなく、議論が行われているようなものです。 この
一般的な方向性は
、
科学者が脳の活動を
脳自体の特徴としてどのよう
に解釈するかを予測
しているということです.
そして、
二重に英語でこれの名前を忘れたと言ってください。
申し訳ありませんが
、根本的に非アクティブな合理性によると、ここでの文字通りの推論の意味ではありません。
これは、生成モデル自体が予測推論を表示および実行するという、より論争の的になっている主張を意味するものではありません。
これは、
この
組み合わせに根本的かつ積極
的な合理性を提供するための予測処理への非常にデフレ的な読み取り
であり、モデルによる2018年の論文のキックオフ
です。
生物が
そのニッチの内部表現モデルを持っていることには従いませ
ん
代わりに、
生物は原因であるモデルであり、
統計的規則
性は、モデルである表現型を反映する環境に反映され
ます。
これは、最近同僚と私が通知したものに関連しています。
生物がどのように世界を生み出すかという考えについて話して
きました。
これは、生物
と環境が歴史
的に歴史的に決定
されているという考えであり、流れの遺伝的スケールでは、これ
はニッチ構築の考えを通じて説明できます。
有機体はその環境で活動しており、
十分に安定している場合、変化を促進します。  ey はその子孫によって継承される可能性が
あり、これらの変化
は、その進化経路を導く新しい進化的圧力圧力を提供します
。同様のアイデアは、ニッチ構築と生態学的心理学に
関連する今回の他の説明でも調査されている
ため、その異議に対する私の応答は次のとおりです。
合理的に行動するということは、ある意味で予測とその最小化を通じて
、環境との熟練した関与を達成することを意味し
ます.
私は
その特徴付け
を喜んで受け入れます.
無意味な予測とそれらの最小化に
は、入力の選択と、世界への関与
のマナーにおける相互能力の調整が含まれます。
これは、
まさに過激でアクティブな性格の主な主張である
ため、その
程度まで、予測処理は
敵ではなくむしろ敵であると思います
uh
到着ではなく c のこの考えの嘘よりも 他に
も互換性の問題があり
ますが、ここでは触れ
ていませんが、今日思いついたのはこれ
だけです。
質問があれば書い
てください メモを集めて、まず
話し合いを始め
ましょう もう一度お話しいただきありがとう
ございます 現在の立場
でこれらの質問を
するようになった経緯と
、この分野への関心がどのように発展した
かについて少し話してください。 興味深いアイデアがたくさんありました。
あなた
がどのようにしてこのフレーミングにたどり着き、意見を明確
にしたかについてもっと知りたいと
思いました
私は博士論文を書いていたと思います.
それはおそらく2007年か何か
だったと思い
ます.合理性は
最終的に世界が関与するものでなければならないという考えについて議論していました.
私があなたに示したように、私があなたに示したように、ええと、
特定の人々との具体化された時代の中で、
それは本質的に必要である必要があります
演技や実践など、そして知覚などの世界を含む
、もちろん合理性
は残りますが、よく考える傾向があります。 帰化可能な概念のような
もの のレベルに
引き下げることができないもの 特定のダイナミックな関与によって説明できる知覚のような方法で縮小することはできませ
んでした.
おそらく
これは膝の問題です
.
他の文脈では、プロの組み合わせと特定の適合性
を提供する方法で明確に表現されていない
場合、知覚が与えられ
、これが与えられた次元の神話であると暗示されるためです.
最初は、
おそらくこれ
は何らかの神話のようなものであり、
ここで能動的認知に取り組んでいる
と思っていましたが、そうではないと思います
致命的ではない理由は
、ステップ認識やコンセプトなどを含む
その他の基本的な組み合わせの形を解釈する代わりに、
おそらく
他の方向から、
自然化されていないレベルで合理性を縮小しようとすることを主張することができなかったから
です。
それが動機であり、
非常に長いレビュープロセスでした。
私の最初の論文の最初のバージョン
の読者は非常に良かったと
思います。彼らは完全に正しかったと思います。
結局、私は提案を支持しましたが、彼
は非常にうーん
、彼らは
それは別の文学で
あり
、通常は
活動主義や身体認識との会話にはならない多くの参考文献であるため、それはより
良いものだったと思います。
私の議論を進めるために同じ用語で問題がある
ので、それは私がかき集めたものであり、そのシステム
についてあまり考えていませんでしたが、それは
私が望むものだと思います
戻ってきて、
おそらく誰かが
この数年でそうしたかもしれません
が、覚えているかどうかはわかりません
が、活動主義
と贈り物の神話との関係は
非常に明白であるように思われます
ですから、それ
は私たちが探求できることだと思います
が、論文の最前線にあったものはありません
が
、あらゆる意味で同時に合理性について話すという考えが
ありました
ええと
、哲学的な観点から彼に電話したことについてたくさん読んでいたとき
、もちろん、私は言ったように
、アプローチの技術と形式に精通してい
ません
が、そこでの哲学的な結果に興味があり、
よく考えました
クラークの
引用が示す
ように、合理性についてずっと
話すことができるので、ここで比較するものがあるかもしれません.
それは
素晴らしい背景です。ありがとうございまし
た.与えられた神話とは
何か、その神話が発生した文脈は何か、与えられた
神話を持ち出した後、どこに行くべきかを説明していただけないでしょうか.
私はそれを概念として見たからです. あなたが
織り込んだので、それについてはどうでした
か、それを与える途中で、
私の哲学の好みに応じて、いくつかの可能なギブンスがありますが、最も古典的には、以前
の心の分野では、
与えられるべき知覚の内容を取ります
合理的に祈り、特定の
インプットがマインドによって受け取ら
れ、マインドがそれを解釈するように祈り
ます。売り手は
、この問題を心の
燃料を増やすだけでなく、問題として説明したことで有名です。
合理主義者にとって
は、しかし反対側では、合理的とは
通常、合理的な直観が
与えられたものと
見なされます。
ある意味
では与えられた認識レベルがあり、精神は
それを解釈しなければなり
ませんが、このように与えられた場合、それは接触点を持たず
、何との間に交点もありません。
マインドが何をしようと、この基本的な
支配のレベルなので、私の考えは、所与の神話
にコミットしているという告発を避けることですが、
これ
もまた、ナチビストの文学では明示されているものではありません
が
、そうであるように思われるものです.
つまり、この種の比較で開発することは可能ですが、
それ
は明らかにそこにあるわけではありませんが
、ギブンズ
が知覚コンテンツは
本質的にすでに概念的であると言う
ためにそれらを解決する1つの方法です。たとえば、ジョー・マクダウェルはどのように
あなたが知覚を知っていることをより多く心に留めていますえ
えと、ジョークには字幕が付属して
おり
、あなたが
そうであるように世界を解釈しますが
、ええと、何らかの方法であなたが合理性を知っていることを分かりやすくすることだと思います そして
、組み合わせの上位層は
、それらをコミットせずに分析のために、より少ないコンテンツでそれらを考えようとします。
したがって、厳密に
言えば、基本的なレベルの組み合わせから切り離されたコンテンツのレベルで言えば、それが
私が考える1つの方法です。
合理性
はこれを行うための1つの重要な概念のようです。なぜなら、
それは通常、すべて
人間だけのものであり
、推論に関連するものであると想定されているからです。
そうであれば、合理性は行動に情報を与えることはできません。
したがって、合理性
が本質的に満足のいく感覚であり、
反応が本質的に満足のない感覚である
場合、これはできません。
これは、2つのドメイン間の交差が行われ
たためです。これは私が避けたかっ
たことですが、先ほどお話ししたように、
この見解を
十分に明確かつ一般的な方法で表現
することは、私たちのレビュアーの推奨により、私はそれ
を削除し、
私はまだ私について考えているということです.  t しかし
、私ができるよりも明確にそれを扱う適切な議論のラインを開発して
いない.非常に一般的
な用語であなたが合理性に関連付けたいくつかの言葉
は、適応性
と熟練度であったので、あなたは何を見ますか.
生物学的機能としての合理性とフィットネスの
関係として そうですね はい はい わかりました それは本質的な関係だと思います それは
おそらく最も
[音楽]
特別な規模での合理的な行動の明白な結果であり、 私たち
は、合理性が特定の種の特徴なのか、それとも個人の特徴なのかについて話し
ます.フィットネスは、これを
この合理的な行動の結果と考えるための重要な概念の1つだと思います.
論文のそれらの問題にそれを入れてください。あなたが知っ
ているようにそれを考えることが可能
だと思います.合理性について考えることへの異論として
それを見ていません.
o この
結果を
、ある意味ですべての生物が受け入れること
まだ本能を失っていない場合は、
その環境に適合しているので
、最小限のレベルの合理性が含まれる可能性があることを確認したいと思い
ます
敵の変化する環境に対処します
が、それは
非常に
リベラルな進歩
的な合理性の概念を持つことの代償です これはその結果である
と私は信じている
ので、フィットネスは合理的な結果であるとあなたは言いました
行動
他の結果または
アリの
コロニーが合理的な範囲で繁栄し
ていると言う以外に、外部からの合理性を
どのように認識すればよいでしょうか。
それ以外の場合は
、それによって単に記述されるか
、または su によって反映される単なる結果から合理的または非合理的な行動のように、もつれを解くために使用できるいくつかの結果がありますか?
リバイバルと
フィットネスは
よく私は
これについて非常に慎重に考えなければなりませんでした.なぜなら私は
この概念を矮小化したくないからです.
すべてが事実のIPSまたは
合理的である.
ええと、特定のケースで
は、私が個人と同等である国を特定できると思います
そのニッチでの自立な
ので、個人レベルでは特に
大丈夫です
ええと
、生存に有害ですが、
ええと、種レベルで
は、この種の行動や結果を特定するためにそのように議論することはより困難です
が
、合理的な考えを矮小化せ
ず、すべてをうまく言うためにはそう思います
生きているということは因数分解されたものであり、1 回の生存に損害を与える
この種の特定の行為を特定する
必要がある
ため、アリのコロニーの場合は
おそらくわかりません。
侵略者を歓迎することは、生存そのものに害を
及ぼすような行動になるだろう
わからない これがそうであるかどうかはわかりません これ
について考えるのは不可能な方法です
私はもっと明確に考えなければなりませんでした
が
、私の
慎重に非常に興味深いので、あなた
はその答えを持ち込んで、Eco Evo Devoがより生物学的な観点から行うのと
同じように、複数の
入れ子になった時間スケールのよう
なプレゼンテーションで、ニッチ構造がどのように
遅い系統発生プロセスとより
急速な発生プロセスの間のギャップを埋めるかを見て
いきます。 この
埋め込まれたマルチスケールの考慮
事項は、コンテンツ
が 1 つの本体にローカライズされるか、コンテンツが
複数のエンティティに分散されるか、
複数のエンティティに分散さ
れる合理性など、コンテンツの概念にどのように関連するか。
また、あなたが提供した引用から
水平的でモジュール化された
概念を
呼び出すようなものでもあります。
対象の空間的時間スケールとシステム
ああ、わからない
これに完全に答えられるかどうかはわかりませんが、正確さとしてのコンテンツについて
話している場合、ええとのレベルでそう思われ
ます 象徴的
思考
の条件 幸いなことに、それは 1 人の個人に限定されたものではなく、
公に共有されて
いると言わざるを得ないので
、この結果の 1 つは、情報サイトである
推論のさまざまなパターンを考えることができるということ
です。 さまざまな時間など、コンテンツ情報について
さまざまなレベルのさまざまなルールを開発したことがわかり
ます。これは
、コンテンツがローカライズされていると言うのがもっともらしいと思います。
合理性のために、
[音楽]
は特定の行動を特定できると思います。
もしそれがこれらに当てはまるなら
有機体
とその環境の間の相互作用 そのニッチなので、
おそらく
ここで合理性と内容として異なる答えを与えることができるでしょ
う
組織の内容
は頭の中で
起こるものではなく、ある意味でそこにあるものだと言いたいです
他人の量とこれ
は私の哲学
が少なくとも60年代から
持っているものです私の哲学者は
コンテンツが外部的に個別化されているという考えについて議論されてき
ました. たとえば、ヒラリー・パトナム
やタイラー・バージなどは、
精神的内容は
共同体レベルまたは社会レベルで個別化され
ているが、その一方で、
合理性は原則として特定の行動で個別化される可能性があると考えています
が、
それは個人の
目標と それが生息するニッチ
など もちろん、ここには実際の変数が
あり、行動を特定するためにも重要になる可能性があります
合理
的かどうか ありがとうございます ええと、本当に心に残ったフレーズの1つは、
おそらくあなたの仕事の基礎点で
あり、その行動に焦点を当てているので
、あなたがどのように行動し、実践したかについて
聞きたかっただけです 今日ここにいる彼らは、これらの
用語が
どのように
扱われ、行動と実践とノウハウの扱いに関して、今日
では物事がどのように異なる
のか.
ええと
、非常に現代的な哲学からの傾向がある
と思いますが、認知科学の最初の波では
、知覚を
環境を分類する能力と考え
、個別の
たとえば
、カップが私の左側に
あることを知っていることを認識することは、そのような特性を検索するものがあることを知ることの問題です
私の左とこれは、世界
に対する一種の命題的態度であることを知っている
ので
、活動主義
と生態学的心理学についても興味深いことだと思います。
今世紀は、
知覚
を世界のこれらの偉大な特性を分類することでは
なく、行動の可能性を明らかにすることの問題として考える
ことであり、これは、知識などの
流行の用語でそれを説明するとしたら、私たちはそう
するでしょう.
カーブが自分の左側にあることを知っ
て
いても、コーヒーを飲み
たい場合やカップとして使用したい場合に、カップをつかんでやりたいことをする方法を知っているということです。
文鎮にはさまざま
なサイレント特性があり、これは
非常にそうでしたが、アクティビズムと生態学的
心理学、およびその他の認識の具現化されたビューは、シフで
大部分が成功している
と思います この議論をこの
時点まで行っていると思いますが、より
伝統的な認知科学では、環境の方法を説明する
ことによって有機体が知覚されるという考えがまだ
あると思います。
あなたが
刺激の源
について推測しているという考え
は、脳や
認知システム
が世界が
アジェンダシステムが世界との関わり方を知っていると言うのではなく、環境は
まあまあです。活動家や生態
心理学者が作ろうとしているのは
、予測に取り組んでいるということだと私は信じています。
コーディングと自由エネルギーの原則
などは、これらの概念、これらの
フレームワークが、kubernetes システムが関与する方法を知っているという最小限のアイデアである可能性がある
ことを示すことです。  Kindle
システムは
世界がそうであると推測しているので、これは
説明の1つの方法だと思い
ますが、最初に大きな問題がある場合は、哲学的にもそうです。
過去数
十年間
、クラウドを縮小してそれを知ることはできないかどうかについての巨大な議論
がありました。また、あなたはそれ
を知っていることから独立した概念として、これ
と他の背景を持っており、
一方を他方に還元できるかどうかなど だから
私はそれが止まらないと思います.あなたは
ええと、私は
彼らがまだ
ノウハウを扱うことができるかどうかの背景問題で
あり、
とにかくこれは何かである. 私も
最近取り組んでい
ます。言いたいことがたくさんあります。特に言語コミュニケーションに関してはとても
興味深いアイデアです。それ
は指と月に少し似
ていて、月について話しているのですが、指
は それがどこにあり、私たちはポインターについて話しているのではなく
、参照について話している
ので
、文化的な言語
または書かれた学術的談話で社会認知的コミュニケーション形式を使用
して、それをじっと見つめたり、それを再想像したり、
見えるものでさえ見ることができます
それを知っていることの頂点のようになり、それでもそれを知っているように見ること
論文をどのように読むかという質問があると
思います はい、もちろんそうです はい、ええと思い
ます 非常に大きな問題です。なぜなら、
あなたがノウハウの問題として言及し
たように、これらの負の能力を取り扱おうとすると、たとえばコミュニケーションについてまだ何かを見逃しているように見えるからです。
一方で、これは私の
直感ですが、
原則として
、あなたが言ったことを理解
し、それに反応しようとすることは、
言語的にどのように行動するかを知ることの問題であると話すことができます
が、私は、高レベルの認知主義者を治療するこの運動でさえ、
t ノウハウの問題で、
まだ何かが
抜け落ちています 個人的には
満足しています 個人的には満足しています
たとえば、
それが含まれていないとは言わないで、非常に適切にコミュニケーションします
が、少なくとも
実用的な知識以上のものが必要
だと思うだけではありませんが、ここでの鍵は、
実用的な知識を基本的
で他の種類に必要なものと考えることです。
この種の交換に関与するために必要な他の種類の知識については
、おそらくこれが1つのレイヤーである
可能性があります。より有益な回答を得るに
は、これについてさらに説明する必要があると確信してい
ますが、これは
少なくとも私の現在の立場は、世界や他者と
の関わりの基礎をどのように提供するかということではありません
が、ある時点で、複雑な種類の非常に説明するために、
他の種類の理解を発展させることができなければなりません。
あなたが言ったように論文を読むなど、私たちが日常生活で行っている交換は、
私は同意
します、それを基礎として知っていることをフレーミングし、次に
ノウハウを回復することは挑戦であり
、家や家を制定するなどの基礎的な認知プロセスから始めることも挑戦です。 これらの
ノウハウの断片を再構築する
ことは、必ずしも単純な課題でさえあるとは限り
ませんが、よりリミナルな生態学的認知アプローチから
象徴的な
命題宣言的言語
などの認知プロセスを組み立てるという課題に直面する
か、チューリングから生態学的なものを回復しようとするかという課題に直面することを認識します。
ある意味では、
あなたは生態学的にもっともらしい基礎的認知プロセスのグラウンディングを支持して話しているように見えます。
そして
、超高層ビルの組み立てに取り組ん
でいます。はい、はい、まったくそうです
あなたが言ったように、
このような説明を
左下または上から下に提供しますが、私は
もちろん、ウェブ
アプローチの方が有利だと思います。別の理由でもあると思います。
出発点は、
私たちが世界とどのように相互作用するかの生物学的説明である
ように思われ、その逆ははるかに
難しいようです。 体の形態
などの生物学的な問題をどのように考え出すかを
説明するには、まずそれを説明する必要があるように思われ
ます。
少なくとも私は
それ
がボトムアップアプローチであると思います。ある意味でより
統合的である可能性
が
あるということは、ある意味で私たちに
有利であるように
思われるということです。
コンピューターをゼロからプログラムする
には、抽象コンピューターまたは仮想コンピューターである可能性がある
ため
、特定の実施形態
を持つ
必要さえありませ
ん。
動的なステートメントとロジック プロセスは、より動的なもの、または
環境と相互作用するものになりますが
、ロジックとシリコンを基盤とするフル スタック エンジニアリングのようなプロセスは、
私たちがここにたどり着いた方法とはまったく異なり
ます。
あなたは、
査読の前と最中と
後で、論文の執筆中と出版後に
何が
変わったの
かを
少し
知りました 関連する
次のステップとして、それがあなたのためのものであるか、
一般的なものであるかにかかわらず、私たち
は脳の測定を探して
いますか? 森の中のビデオカメラを
探していますか?
あなたの
発展
はそれは素晴らしい質問
です
私は私が外国語レベルを使用する方法に完全に満足しているとは思いません
これらのいずれかが実行されるかどうかわかりません
ou ええと、正直に言って
、原則として
他の経験的な用語で実行できるかどう
かはわかりませ
んが、ええと、今日は少し違った方法で書くと言っているのではありません。
もともと論文ですが、再構成
したい点がいくつかある
と思いますが、それらも承認されていません
。彼は新しい論文を持っていたと思います
が、将来的には可能性がありますが、これは
神話などの質問が
与えたものです。 まだ哲学的な
問題
と概念的な問題は
私を悩ませていますが、私は
これらのアイデアをより注意深く発展させる機会をまだ見つけて
いません. まだこの機会を待って、
それをさらに
詳しく説明し、どこまで到達できるかを確認しますが、
まだわかりません このアイデアの将来の展開がどうなるかはわかりません
が、ええと、私は取り組んできました いくつかの
孤立した
問題について
ここ数年、このアプローチについて、私
は情報と科学的理解の概念
と、生態学的および組み合わせの活動家のための情報を扱ってきました。
最近では、仮想現実と知覚認識についていくつかの大学と協力しています。
興味深い質問を見つけて、それら
にどのように対処できるかを確認するために調査を行うのが好きです
が、必ずしも
そのように1行の推論に縛られているとは限らないので、これ
は私が働いていたときに起こったことです
それが非常にクールな主題だと思った場合の合理性、
そしてええと、私はまだ
そう思っていますが、
戻ってきて自分が望んでいたことを再構成する時間がありませんでしたが、
おそらく
近い将来いつかはわかりませんが、もっと
私が取り組んでいる最新のことは
、細胞の合理性に関係していません
が、いくつかの製品
は間違っている可能性があると
思います。
ビネーションは、
明らかに
忍耐力と視覚的環境から何かが
欠けているためです。もちろん、私が誰かの
場合、たとえば
私がある種の
脅威にさらされている視覚的環境にいる場合、恐怖に似た何かを感じるかもしれません
が、 私は自分の命を本当に恐れているわけではなく
、仮想現実にいる人が脅威から逃げるのは理にかなっていると想像してください。
仮想の脅威
など、これはこれです、これは
私が取り組んでいるものです 多分それ
は、
急進的で積極
的な合理性の考えに戻るポイントを提供することであり、実際、論文
が受理されたばかりなので、
前に言ったように、私はここ数
日、私が証拠を修正していたのでとても忙しかった.
同僚と私は決して比喩的ではありませんでした.私も
過去数週間で論文の修正版を提出するためにタイトなスケジュールでした.そして私
は証拠を手に入れました.
ああ.
合理性の ue し
たいが、わからないかどうかは
わからない その展開を本当に予測することはできない
が、一般的に
は、元のアイデアにはまだ同意するが
、少し違った形で組み立てる
VRのポイントについては、
他にも言いたいことがたくさんあると
思いますが、タイトルのバーチャルリアリティを思い出しました。これは
仮想化であり
、
認知行動計画
が私たちの体が持っていないポリシーを楽しませることができるのと同じように.
それらを評価してそれらに反対することを選択するだけなら
、私たち
は空想にふけることができます精神的には反事実の気まぐれなポリシー選択プロセスを持ってい
ます
が、私たちの形態はライフラインのようなもの
です。実際に
棚から落ちた場合、それは 傷つく
と、仮想現実で
具体化されます。
知覚体験は、文字通り
、生存に不可欠な状況を仮想化したものです。
そのため、
自分が棚の上にいるように見えるかもしれ
ませんが、平らな床にい
て、その状況にいるのです。
あなたがビデオゲームの
外の一種の認知的観察者なら、
何が起こるかを見る
ために私が
落ちるのは合理
的だと言うかもしれません. ゲームでは、
[音楽] と [音楽
] の境界線がぼやけているようなものです。体の臨界性がぼやけてい
ます。ええと、あなたはこれについてもっと考えたことがあると思います。
これらのシステムについて私たちが考え、使用し、設計する方法
これが、
私たちが論文を書く動機となった質問であり、
NADAがそれらに与えた質問
です。技術文献
では、多くの研究者
が ええと、ええと、視覚を
一種のイリュージョンとしてイラストとして扱い
ますが、一方でそれは VR でのみ機能するため、少し気になりました。
セット
とええと、ユーザーが一種の幻想の下にあると言うのはとても奇妙に思え
ますが
、一方で、それ
は実際には認知ではないようです。
たとえば、VRでリンゴを見ると
、栄養を与える余裕はありません
が、ゲーム内では理にかなっ
ていますが、実際の環境でリンゴを受け取ったのとは異なり
、栄養を与えることができます
それは私が食べることができるものですが
、VR ではできません ふりをすることができるので、私たちはその平面
へのほのめかしのこの概念を作り出しました。
私たちがゲームに参加していることを知っている機器を装着したため、誤解されてい
ます。
メタファーがあり、メタファーの可能性について
人々が非常に楽観的で
ある可能性について非常に懐疑的であるため、これは現在ホットなテーマだと思います。  rse
と何人かの著者
は、厳密に言えば、私たちはシミュレーションの中にいる可能性があると本当に考えてい
ますが、現在のテクノロジーが
私たちに示している最高のテクノロジーは、それが非常に限られており
、特定の環境にいるふり
をすることができるということです。
この
視覚的環境における合理性について考える新しい新しい考え方を提供するかもしれません。おそらく
ロシア人は、その環境
が言われたことを行い、岩棚から飛び降りて
何が起こるかを観察し、一方
でそうすることの行動面で
人々が実際に感じることがあります。 恐怖と人々
は、仮想現実で恐怖症のために通りに直面しています。
ええと、そこには多くの
興味深い質問があり
ます。将来の研究のために、私たちは
それに戻ることができます。それは
、アップルが現実の生活でどのように
あなたにとってのカロリーかもしれませんが、ハエのカロリーかもしれません。
ハエを投げる
こともできます。それをハンマーとして使うこともできます。それを正しくペイントすることもできます。
私たちが言うように、アクティブな推論のようなプロセス
は、特定のオブジェクトに対してプログラムされたアフォーダンスを常に超えており、さらに
、VRに関する現在の議論
は、私の専門分野ではなく、完全に逸話的に話しているヘッドセットに重点を
置いています。 ちょっと面白い
です。まるで携帯電話の
議論が
特定のサイズの長方形にのみ焦点を当て
ているかのようです。なぜなら、これはバーチャル リアリティではない
からです。窓越しに見ているようなもので
、話をする別の仲間がいるので
、私の頭には付いていません。
いくつかの技術が持っているモーション追跡機能のいくつかを
持っていますが、それは
ペリーの個人空間のニッチな修正であり、
信号とアフォーダンスを互いにプッシュすることができる
ので、VR フレーミングまたは実際に
は合理性と知覚
認知アクションのフレーミング
を持っています。
1 つの特定の認識またはハードウェア タイプに制約されるだけでなく
、フィールド内のオフラインの人員の合計
から s までの範囲を実行できます。 マトリックスに非常に参加している誰か
はかなり関連しているようです。そうでなければ、新しい
テクノロジーは、小さなバリアントや
ソフトウェアの更新でさえ、
無限に驚き、混乱し続けます。
ええ、境界を定義するのは難しいと思い
ます。つまり、
私たちは交換でここに
います 増加する可能性があると思いますが
、もちろん仮想現実の一種として分類されます。もちろん、あなたがCの心を台無しにしているのを見ています
が、
ええと、ほとんどの場合
、彼らは最近で
はヘッドセットが必要だと言ってドキュメントを見つけていると思います。
時にはコントローラーですが、それ
以外は仮想現実に聞こえますが、
ええ、何かを定義するのは難しいですええと、
それはダンプではなく、
簡単なことではありません。
商業的に言うと、
もちろん仮想現実はヘッドセット
やその他の道具を意味しますが、 当時
の電話や電報で話しているだけの電話は
、その感覚
モダリティとそのアフォーダンスと
のインターフェース上にあったでしょう。 私たちがアクセスできる仮想化は、
今日の別の章のちょうど別の章です。
私たちの論文の一部は
、ある意味で技術的デバイスを具現化することが明らかに必要であると主張すること
でした。それは新しいことではなく、それは
人間である
ことの印です。 分析技術を使用し
て最初から私たちを作ってきた技術的デバイス
を具現化すること
と、たとえば仮想現実内で
、
あなたが制御する生き物をより豊かにするようにプログラムされている場合でも、デバイスを非常に巧みに具現化できるという事実 新しい
形態 別の形態
たとえば、たとえそうであったとしても、デバイスを具現化する
ことができるため、非常に上手に発生するだけ
です いくつかの実験では
、たとえば、手首のねじれを
3番目の腕に
マッピングできることが示されています。
あなたの胸と人々から、実際の形態にマッピングされ
ていないこの 3 番目の腕を制御することを学ぶ
ことができますが、ツイスト o
手首の場合、
これは
私たちの論文で説明するものですが、
それができるのはデバイスを具現化するためです。
それは幻想であることがわかります。
実際に
は、私が人間であることの一部であり、
技術デバイスを刺繍すること
です。 つまり
、仮想芽と非仮想芽の区別が曖昧になることはわかってい
ます。これは、このクールに対処する1つの方法だと思います。
他に話したいことはあり
ますか、それともプレリュードのようなものがありますか
この論文について議論する機会を与えていただき、ありがとうございました。
私にとってはとても良かったです。本当に
楽しかったです。
これらの問題について議論するのに非常に快適で快適な環境でし
た。もう一度
感謝します。素晴らしい議論と
重要なトピックに感謝します。 いつでも喜んでまた
お話させて
いただきます。